أدت الفضيحة التي أحاطت بوفاة
جمال كيكوتشي إلى جر موقع تويتر
في الوحل على جبهات متعددة ،
مما زاد من الضغط على مخزون الشبكات الاجتماعية ،
وزعم تقرير متفجر في صحيفة The New York Times أن
موظفًا على تويتر قد تم فصله في عام 2015 بعد
شكوك
استخباراتية سعودية أقنعته.  للوصول إلى
حسابات المعارضين وقبل
أن تنشر صحيفة نيويورك تايمز تقريرها ،
أوقف تويتر شبكة من الحسابات
التي يبدو أنها تدفع
بخط الحكومة السعودية بشأن فضيحة جمال
كيكوتشي وفقًا
لشخص مطلع على الموقف ،
اكتشف الباحثون BOTS مع Pro.
الرسائل السعودية التي كانت تشارك نفس
المحتوى بنفس الترتيب باستخدام نفس
الهاشتاج مما يشير إلى
جهد مؤتمت أو شبه آلي على مستوى الشبكة على
الرغم من عدم وجود دليل مباشر من
الباحثين أو تويتر لإثبات أن
الحسابات خاضعة لسيطرة الحكومة السعودية التي
شاركها تويتر  معلومات قليلة أو
معدومة حول هذه القصص ولكن
كل ذلك يأتي  قبل
تقرير Twitter الفصلي هذا الخميس ، حيث من
المرجح أن يسأل الصحفيون المستثمرون والمحللون ممثلي تويتر
حول مصداقية الحسابات
والرسائل على المنصة وما
تفعله الشبكة الاجتماعية لمكافحة
المعلومات المضللة على طول الطريق من
الولايات المتحدة إلى المملكة العربية السعودية Samuel
Burke  سي إن إن لندن